c'est un meurtre qu'ils ont fait ils
m'ont enlevé mon Thomas tout ça c'est de
la folie furieuse Thomas 16 ans a été
poignardé à mort dans une bagarre
vengeresse par une dizaine d'individus
armée de couteau lors d'une fête de
village dans la Drome 3 jours après
Isabelle la mère de l'adolescent s'est
exprimé pour la première fois pour Paris
Match cet été on l'avait autorisé à
aller à quelques balles de village et
pour celui de crpo il avait hâte c'est
juste à côté de chez nous et sur les 300
ou 400 participants il devait connaître
80 % des jeunes ce mardi neuf suspects
ont été interpellés par le GIGN dont le
principal suspect hauteur du coup de
couteau mortel un homme de 20 qui habite
roman suriser une enquête a été ouverte
pour meurtre et tentative de meurtre en
bande organisée et les autres suspects
étroitement surveillés ont été
interpellés dans la région de Toulouse
après avoir fui leur domicile samedi
soir à crépool alors qu'un bal de
l'hiver rassemblant 350 personnes
étaient organisé un groupe d'individus
extérieur à cette commune de 532
habitants avaient sauvagement attaqué la
salle des fêtes des habitants qui
souhaitent rester anonymes racontent
l'origine selon eux de cette violente
attaque un jeune aurait mal pris la
blague d'un autre jeune rugby man il se
serait énervé puis il aurait été expulsé
de la soirée par le vigile avec son ami
les jeunes du quartier m'ont raconté que
les deux garçons sont partis de crépole
car là-bas il n'y a aucun réseau pour
téléphoner ils ont appelé leurs amis de
la cité et ils sont revenu en bande à la
fin de la soirée pour se venger puis les
coups de couteau ont volé et Thomas a
été poignardé à mort selon le directeur
de l'Institut pour la Justice Pierre
Marie SEV cette attaque mortelle et en
bande organisée choque car elle demeure
pour le moment inhabituelle loin d'être
un fait isolé elle met en lumière un
phénomène grave et nouveau l'apparition
de la violence dans les territoires
traditionnellement les plus calmes de
France ce mercredi une marche blanche
était organisé dans la ville voisine de
roman suriser à l'initiative du club de
rugby de roman péage auquel Thomas
[Musique]
appartenait